Ein neues Kuschelhormon
wurde entwickelt.
WLAN kann man sich jetzt
auch drucken.
Andere drucken dafür
mit lebender Tinte.
Schwule Männer
haben öfter ältere Brüder.
Und betrunken
beherrschen wir Fremdsprachen besser.
Und damit herzlich willkommen
bei Science News.
*Titelmusik*
Freunde der Sonne, setzt euch,
wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren.
In der Welt der Wissenschaft
passiert so viel.
Ich kann nicht über alles
Videos machen.
Deswegen habe ich heute direkt
fünf brandaktuelle Meldungen
aus der aktuellen Forschung
für euch. Let's go.
Nummer eins: Kuschelhormon 2.0.
Das Molekül Oxytocin
wird als Kuschel- oder Liebeshormon
stark gehypt.
Seine Funktion im Körper ist,
wie bei so vielen Hormonen,
komplex und vielfältig.
Vor allem berühmt ist es aber,
für seine Rolle bei
zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen.
Z.B. zwischen Mutter und Kind oder
bei romantischen Liebesbeziehungen.
Eingesetzt als Medikament hilft
Oxytocin nicht nur bei Geburten,
sondern potentiell auch
bei Krankheiten wie Krebs,
Autismus, Angststörungen uvm.
Allerdings kann das "Kuschelhormon"
als Medikament
auch schädliche Nebenwirkungen
für Herz-Kreislauf
oder die Gebärmutter haben.
Denn Oxytocin spricht nicht nur
den Oxytocin-Rezeptor an.
Sondern auch
den "Vassopressin"-Rezeptor.
Damit ist
eine selektive Wirkung erschwert.
Jetzt haben Forscher
Oxytocin nachgekocht.
Allerdings das Molekül
minimal verändert.
So das es jetzt viel selektiver
nur auf den Oxytocin-Rezeptor geht.
Bleiben wir gespannt,
wie sich das Kuschel-Hormon 2.0
therapeutisch einsetzen lässt.
Nummer zwei: gedrucktes Wifi.
Das, Freunde der Sonne, sind keine
selbstgemachten Kinderspielzeuge.
Sondern 3-D-gedruckte
Haushaltshelfer,
die ohne Strom, übers WLAN mit Handy
oder Laptop kommunizieren können.
Die smarten Gegenstände
beruhen auf einem einfachen Prinzip:
Ein Schalter,
eine Feder, ein Zahnrad
und eine einfache Antenne.
Die Antenne kann ohne Strom
Signale empfangen
und aussenden, z.B. an ein Handy.
Indem sie das WLAN-Signal
entweder reflektiert
oder absorbiert.
Dieses physikalische Phänomen
nennt man "ambiant backscatter".
Immer wenn sich das Rädchen dreht,
berührt der Schalter die Antenne.
Immer wenn der Schalter
die Antenne berührt,
verändert das die Reflexion
des WLAN-Signals.
Wenn man das Ganze z.B.
auf eine Waschmittelflasche setzt
und den Verbrauch mechanisch
an das Zahnrädchen koppelt,
kann der Verbrauch über das Handy
getrackt werden.
Und könnte einstellen,
dass Waschmittel neu bestellt wird,
bevor es leer geht.
Nummer drei: Drucken mit Bakterien.
Wir bleiben beim 3D-Druck,
gehen aber von kommunizierenden
Gegenständen zu lebenden Organismen.
Schweizer Forscher
drucken mit lebender Tinte.
Genannt "Flink",
functional living ink.
Was da drin lebt, sind Bakterien.
Iiih, Bakterien!
Nichts, iiih, Bakterien!
Es gibt sehr viele gute Bakterien.
So welche, die schädliche Giftstoffe
in reine Zellulose umwandeln.
Mit denen
möchte man Zellulose-Hüllen
für Organtransplantationen drucken
oder künstliche Haut herstellen.
Bisschen creepy
ist das schon mit der Barbie.
Nummer vier: Homosexualität
entsteht im Mutterleib.
Und zwar anscheinend bei Müttern,
die sehr viele Söhne bekommen.
Wer viele ältere Brüder hat,
ist häufiger schwul.
Diese Beobachtung nennt man den
"fraternal birth order effect".
Nur hatte man bislang
keine biologische Erklärung dafür.
Kanadische Forscher
untersuchten das Blut von Müttern,
die mit Jungs schwanger waren.
Und sie fanden
eine erhöhte Konzentration
eines bestimmten Antikörpers,
für ein Protein, das nur bei Jungs
oder Männern gebildet wird.
Die Theorie ist jetzt,
dass dieser Antikörper-Konzentration
im Blut der Mutter
mit jeder männlichen
Schwangerschaft steigt.
Diese Antikörper könnten so Einfluss
auf das Gehirn des Babys haben,
dass die sexuelle Orientierung
dadurch beeinflusst wird.
Wohlgemerkt sind das
sehr neue Ergebnisse
basierend auf einer
eher kleinen Studie.
Daher sind sie
mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Aber interessant ist es allemal.
Und Nummer fünf: betrunken
sprechen wir besser Fremdsprachen.
Das fanden
holländische Forscher heraus.
Und zwar sollten Niederländer
die Niederländisch-Skills
deutscher Muttersprachler bewerten.
Diejenigen, die vorher
ein Gläschen Wein getrunken hatten,
wurden besser bewertet
als die Nüchternen.
Solltet ihr euch
vor der Englisch-Klausur betrinken?
Ich bezweifle es
und die Forscher auch.
Da im Experiment nur sehr moderate
Mengen an Alkohol getestet wurden,
außerdem auch nur
die oralen Sprach-Skills.
Wahrscheinlich hat das Ganze nur
mit einem gewissen Grad
an Enthemmung zu tun.
Bei größeren Mengen Alkohol ist mit
einer Verbesserung nicht zu rechnen.
Oh la la, qu-est-ce-que chose?
Baguette.
Alle Paper,
über die ich heute gesprochen habe,
sind natürlich unten verlinkt.
Danke noch mal
für euer sehr positives Feedback
zu diesem Science-News-Format.
Ich werde euch in Zukunft
regelmäßig auf dem Laufenden halten.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)